est ce que je peux dire des autres
persos ou pas je fais ce que tu veux
c'est une émission on a décrit ensemble
oui bien sûr pas toi tu t'es
je me suis fait gronder de la personne
ce qui serait alors c'est qui m'a appelé
et m'a dit écoute je ne verrai mon
copain ah bon voilà qu'elle a trop de
prendre à ses abonnés
de récolter chez bar à quelques quelques
jours
si michel blanc vers l'italie
et ce n'est rien resté deux jours entre
deux jours et six mois médias mais les
renards partout voilà j'arrive et c'est
toi et c'est vrai que d'abord tête
extrêmement généreux à cette époque à la
grande époque on va dire et tf1 gagné
aux alentours de 2 millions d'euros par
an à peu près au moins un peu moins ou
d'argent est ce que je peux dire ou pas
tu sais où tu me dis non un jour sur la
cuisine et à l'époque lutte est
mensualisé sur les impôts oui et donc je
regarde comme ça et je vois ce que tu
paies par impôt mensuel ouais parce que
13 c'est normal je puis voilà je vous
l'avais déjà dit je viens le montant à
115 72 mille euros par mois d'impôts
prélevés le 1er du mois alors plus
l'emprunt sur les voitures plus
l'emprunt sur l'appartement et où en
gros le 1er du mois il ya cent mille
balles qui partait ça plus en plus bien
sûr à la vache a très bien et j'essaie
de cette émission vous avez souvent dit
avec cyril et tout ça nous aidera croûte
et le fameux costa davis l'année liszt
et des lys à saint raymond mais moi ce
que j'aimerais qu'on prône aujourd'hui
c'est pal après c'est comme en côte il
gagne 2 millions d'euros sur tf1 et
avant la m6 tu gagnais à peu près 60
mille euros par mois pour animer la
stalle la nouvelle star bref
plus encore bien ses tours de chant
tu as vendu ta société effectivement
deux fois deux fois autant aux 3
millions d'euros annoncés un peu moins
tu as touché à pognon koudad personne
n'a jamais touché et comment comment en
fait justement là bas à quel moment ça
se passe là bas ce que tu sais quoi
c'est le divorce et cooke et à quel
moment ça le divorce anas le divorce
j'aurais parlé aux pourparlers
s'annoncent à n'être pas et c'est normal
quand on est marié sous leur commune
alors oui on a construit un patrimoine
ensemble quand on sait par où coupe en
deux ouais là voilà donc ça j'ai compris
vous aimez perdre est la fameuse
victoire en charente a dit j'ai été
arnaqué fait coincer c'est très simple
j'ai je me suis pas caché j'ai eu tort
d'ailleurs les pommes tout dire que
c'était très dur de gagner de l'argent
et de le montrer
pasqua gt gt les greens j'étais fier de
ma réussite est très fier de la réussite
je trouve qu'il ya pas de honte à
réussir non j'ai volé l'argent à
personne et que terry grant est d'accord
mais comme d'autres sauf qu'en télé ils
disent tous qu'ils me lever il regagne 2
sans
rooney on passera à leurs enfants d'un
appareil
en plus laurent il était le producteur
et oui
comment s'est passée cette histoire
arrive le ranger arrive alors c'est vrai
ça je m'explique - effectivement j'avais
qu'aux cantons et j'ai tout dilapidé ses
faux j'avais acheté un appartement
j'avais acheté une maison de campagne
j'avais acheté des biens que vous avez
un patrimoine très vertébré il sauf que
dans ce patrimoine quand j'ai divorcé
les plénières qui étaient des mots bien
l'appartement à paris la maison de
campagne moi c'est elle a été vendue
loge les dégeler voilà c'était c'est ma
femme qui l'a pris ce qui est très
normal voilà c'est ça la normandie quand
on a perdu trouville voilà je n'ai gardé
que des biens qui à l'époque je ne
savais pas été bien toxiques mclaren en
gros 3 millions d'euros placés que je
pensais payer à terme avec un crédit et
à terme j'arrivais un pécule 2,3
millions plus que ça avait dû nous
baignons en 20 ans sauf que quand tu
quoque effectivement j'ai vendu ma
société
urbanisée pourrait que j'ai vendu très
bien mais contre l'intégrité de mes
revenus qui allaient dans la société un
autre feu cheikh way qui te retrouver
salariés aux alentours de 2 millions
unis ce qui est beaucoup d'argent déjà
vous retirer un million d'impôts ouais
et surtout j'ai pas très j'ai pas
anticiper un le train de vie que j'avais
ça c'est mon erreur je t'apprends la
faute pour moi et surtout le fait que je
2 2 d'un salaire énorme tous les mois
c'est devenu je suis revenu sur la
salers qui avoue paraître gigantesque
mais qui était dix fois inférieur ce que
j'ai pour moi c'était comme un dix mille
euros par mois dix mille euros par mois
ce qui est un très bon salaire on était
sur place tu remarques furent même ça
mais quand tu es dans la mienne mais bon
donc effectivement c'est délicat de
parler d'argent donc
moi ça vous m'interrogez là je peux pas
j'ai pas chroniqueur mais j'aurais
répondu
la vérité elle est aussi mort pendant un
an quand tu es sur un paquebot que tu
divorces que tu dis [ __ ] faujas de
pago pago s'arrête pas on s'en remettent
ça s'arrête en 1 kilomètre quand tu
réalises que tu as qu'il faut freiner
j'ai freiné trop tard ça c'est ma faute
mais après quand j'ai vu qui c'était un
peu la panique entre temps j'ai été viré
de tf1 tout en restant sur la chaîne
conne et avec toujours de l'argent que
je les y ai qui partait chez banide
jusque tout à fait normal j'ai bien sûr
quand j'ai réalisé qu'il fallait mettre
tournai-lille bon bah je vais vendre ce
que j'ai acquis a appris que je pensais
être le bon prix de 3 millions on m'a
dit que mes biens va les 250000 euros et
pourquoi pas ce que j'ai investi dans la
merde voilà c'était les femmes nos
investissements dans des hôpitaux diab
et j'avais déjà y avait plein de choses
mais il y avait des choses qui étaient
bien vivants du tout de suite nous
piquent d'autres choses qui étaient très
mauvaises l'accord n'est jamais plus bas
et maintenant sur une barque tu freines
plus vite ou quoi maintenant
vous l'avez après et antoine plains pas
je suis très heureux eric dumont moi
j'ai une journée que j'ai maté de bosser
ce que même pour ça allait pas j'étais
toujours sur tf1 puis préfet d'autres
choses mais c'est vrai que au niveau
poillion ça a été à des as mais j'en
suis partiellement responsable parce
qu'il fait je ne vais pas anticiper
après quand tu penses avoir trois lions
de côté et qu'on fait à 300 me ou 250
milles ça fait un trou dans la caisse
aujourd'hui les dettes elles sont
combien bas je les paye maintenant
régulièrement je sais pas j'étais à
saint cloud est advenu je pense et ce à
deux millions d'euros des deux têtes
aujourd'hui à des banques des
particuliers par peut tout à bab 2 c'est
un mixte un peu aux deux
avec des gens sur qui la gère quoi et
qu'on salue réalise alors c'est toujours
une question non non tu nous raconter la
saint-valentin combien tu avais dépenser
en magasin
et
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas reconnu à ses portes la
gueule
après voilà effectivement tous les mois
j'ai une grosse partie ouais l'affectif
voilà j'ai des condamnations gros est
parti ce qui est très bien toujours en
bourse qui est affecté à mes dettes ce
qui est normal là tu m'as dit
effectivement y'a pas longtemps que tu
es maintenant trouver un arrangement ok
banque aurait donc là pendant à peu près
cinq ans cette route tous les mois wen
en bourse ouai c'est trop bien mais
beaucoup d'argent ne fais pas ton texte
merde la camionnette bloqué la route
attente elle te ramène tous les soirs
c'est courageux ici c'est quand même
dévoilé énormément je trouve navrant
c'est quand même et là alors on attaque
l'ex ceylan l'office non mais je vais
être j'aimerais excusez moi j'aimerais
parler un petit peu dommage à maquens
n'y a pas ce que c'est une personne que
j'aime énormément qui a beaucoup lutté
dans sa vie qui a gagné des sous mais
les abonnés à personne je suis désolé il
a fait des prime il a été témoin d'une
telle gêne questions d'une chaîne comme
tf1 qui a été une chaîne à l'époque
c'était incroyable ep danse aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui benjamin castaldi il fait
son mea culpa je vais vous dire sinon je
vous dit à vos yeux mais c'est
extraordinaire de faire un meilleur coup
mais on avait beau prix voire devant les
français mais ma question c'est fait
mais je voterai l'attention
qu'elles sont impressionnistes et
deborah c'est aujourd'hui tu rembourses
combien à peu près quand j'étais jeune
et j'ai dit un certain montant si j'ai
dit ah tiens il ya longtemps que je ne
ferai plus jamais de l'argent actuelle
mais je rembourse beaucoup voilà
d'accord c'est plus 70% de meslay fait
tout arrêter de travailler la pâte est
planté en trois mois
inquiet mais question
sinon ça passe enfin que tu n'es plus
sur ces huit aujourd'hui etc tu as des
enfants en bas âge tu as une famille à
nourrir tout ça est ce que tu serais
capable de refaire de faire un métier
normal oui j'avais alors je te les prêts
pour te réponds commun quand j'ai mes
gros problèmes d'ordre dans mon dos mais
sur les prétentieux j'ai une petite
expérience du karting donc quand j'ai
des gros problèmes et j'ai été appelé
pour aller travailler en tant que
salarié dans une boîte américaine parce
que j'ai fais bien volontiers pour un
salaire qui est très confortable qui
n'avaient rien à voir mais bien sûr que
nos frères et bien sûr pc pg pas prévu
voilà bah je voulais j'ai plein de
défauts mais je ne l'étais je suis
honnête j'étais beaucoup d'humilité et
pas de problème à faire des choses qui
paraissent assez vraie résonance donc
effectivement jeunes a parfois tu à
l'insouciance moi ce que je trouve quand
on s'était parlé pendant le coup vide et
que tu m'as dit ma femme est enceinte à
la fin je trouvais ça formidable et à la
fois que tu me disais j'ai un moindre
revenu devant moi si ça s'arrête au bout
d'un mois je peux plus payer mon loyer g
[ __ ] benjamin c'est à un mois de loyer
est ce qu'on fait un enfant mais
encourageant alors ça alors ça
franchement je l'avais d'abord
mais bien sûr mais à finir ça mais sanaa
attend je veux dire moi je me bouge le
cul énormément vous allez retrouver
beaucoup et cyril j'ai plein de projets
une pièce que j'ai écrite avec lui j'ai
une série qui voit là j'ai plein de
projets qui ce qui est en train de bien
avancer donc je me bouge le cul pour
effectivement me m me remettre en selle
et payer mes dettes et voilà mais je ne
suis pas du tout à plaindre je ne me
plains pas cessé la production et à une
production gestion des productions
quelques gestes que nous et danser et
j'adore et je me diversifie dans deux
domaines voilà j'ai des preuves des
projets de fer à de faire plein de
choses d un remake donc honnêtement je
suis très bien dans ma tête ludivine
bébé apprend passera assez large enquête
très fouillée bon sens non pas ça s'est
vraiment fait une question mais pour
soutenir un petit peu ce que disait le
ranelagh il ya quelques instants j'ai la
chance de côtoyer benjamin hors plateau
hors antenne faut savoir que les
personnes malheureusement qui des fois
dépense beaucoup sont les personnes les
plus généreuses et on le veuille ou non
ça aussi c'est un véritable engrenage
benjamin il ya des dizaines de ses amis
qu'il a pu aider par le passé qui lui
ont jamais entendu un euro après et
jusqu'à maintenant alors que le mec il
est rincé même quand je vais chez lui il
veut jamais qu'on ramène quoi que ce
soit c'est toujours lui ça c'est vrai
évoquer mon avenir on était huit et a
insisté pour payer
la vérité c'est pour la partager match
et non pas du tout puissant l'a dit
n'est pourtant ni vers sanaa pour avec
plus de votre nouvelle gens fous et tout
le reste est du genre il faut s'acheter
invités oui c'est vrai mais taper